on november 13th
gunmen and bombers attacked a number of
locations throughout paris
they killed over 120 people and wounded
an even larger number
[Music]
isis otherwise known as the islamic
state claimed responsibility for these
attacks
a group of believers from the soldiers
of the caliphate set out targeting the
capital of prostitution advice
the lead carrier of the cross in europe
paris
in the past isis really hasn't launched
any major terrorist attacks abroad
isis's basic goal is holding on to its
territory in iraq and syria
why change your strategy now one theory
according to the brookings institution's
will mccants is that they're trying to
warn off their enemies abroad
they want to deter further military
action
recently isis has been losing territory
bombing from a us-led coalition which
includes france has hurt the group
they have lost something like 25
of their territory so isis has a problem
it has strong foreign militaries that
are fighting against it and it doesn't
have a good way to fight back at them
so one theory according to mccance is
that the attack in paris is a means of
showing these enemies
that isis will hurt them if they keep
attacking it evidence for this theory
includes the fact that isis recently
attacked a part of lebanon
that's a hezbollah stronghold hezbollah
is a lebanese militia that is fighting
on the same side as bashar al-assad in
syria
nominally an isis enemy similarly
there's strong suspicion that isis
bombed a russian civilian airliner in
egypt
so the idea here is that isis wants to
show potential enemies
that you will pay a price if you attack
isis in syria and to rock
so if ice attack paris it might not have
been out of strength it might have been
out of weakness
[Music]
you